the devastation of Grenfell tower is
hidden from view today but the damage to
the ground on which it stands is
becoming clear an independent study has
found the fire contaminated the soil
with chemicals that could pose a grave
risk to public health for residents of
the Lancaster West Estate rebuilding
their lives nearly two years on it is
confirmation of their worst fears it's
really upsetting it's something that
should have been done from the start it
should have taken nearly two years to do
everyone's affected that live close
because you're always ill a lot of
people ended up coughing really badly I
have to do something now because they
finally got been poor they need to clear
up the soil and the area and there are
thousands of people who live here who've
been affected by this so that I mean
we're talking about huge public health
screening program and this could go on
for this will go on for years and years
and years
this is the source of the contamination
charred remnants of insulation boards
the researchers say gave off deadly
hydrogen cyanide during the fire and
then left potentially deadly chemicals
in the ground afterwards from our
analysis we found number of different
contaminants which we'll have in terms
they're categorized as respiratory
sensitizers that within the long
exposure they will lead potentially to
asthma as well even to a high risk of
getting cancer soil gathered within 200
meters of the tower contained up to 160
times the normal concentration of
cancer-causing chemicals and researchers
are calling for long term health
screening for residents and emergency
responders councillor judith Blakeman is
concerned her residents garden one of
scores in the area may have been
contaminated what worries me now when
even personally because I used to cook a
lot of rhubarb crumbles and my
neighbor's children loved them and
they've eaten them all I don't get
matters to me because I'm old but for
the children it's really worrying public
health England has been monitoring the
air quality around Granville Tower but
not the soil and they say they will
examine this report separate soil
samples are being analyzed by the
Environment Agency but for now the
health advice to locals remains the same
any produce grown around here should be
washed and peeled before being eaten and
anyone gardening should wear gloves a
government spokesman said they take
these findings seriously and that anyone
with health concerns should see their GP
Paul Kelso sky news